[Applaudissements]
coupable
émission exceptionnelle sous toit
pikanews il était sûr
sur mon idole il sera là dans l attente
christian tu l'as de l'est
particularité physique vous alors moi je
suis très douée avec mon corps regardez
bien dérisoire c'est impressionnant mais
qui fait mention
jean michel maire c'est quoi ta part tu
fais rire oui j'arrive à faire un double
avec ma [ __ ] question clavier qui est
avec insupportable on n'entend rien su
des corps habillés ont dit oui à la
question bonjour est ce que ramzi est le
plus grand acteur avec qui tu n'es
jamais tourner en rond dans l'eau
[Rires]
martin amis oui amy est ce que si on te
proposer de tourner un prochain film
avec christian clavier
oui et sans être payés oui accepterait
d'ouvrir gratuitement avec le à
christian est bien sûr qu'au bien sûr et
moi aussi je tourne vers eux avec leurs
idées c'est pas vrai tourner sans être
payés vous êtes payés à christian cadier
encore dans l'ambitieux n'accepterait
pas à moitié sur 200 être payés oui
revenons il faut qu'ils payent pour
donner que moi
méfiance
je suis qu'une chanson
les lots des 10 sur les premières scènes
y aurait des années collège
est ce que tu penses que sherlock holmes
ça vraiment existé oui donc ça s'est il
dit la vérité mais stable dans le paf il
est très puissant et bien oui
arrêtez les mecs ne chômait pas norbert
on sent qu'il ya une ambiance ici c'est
quand même bizarre qui passe de temps
aussi à gages très content dit à maman
ça peut ça peut virer vinaigre de riz ce
que tu as des trucs à nous dire sur le
film et 1 heure des trucs à dire à nos
téléspectateurs il faut quand même
rendre hommage quand même aussi à un
mathieu et son émission qui a été
évidemment comme pour belle et sébastien
très fins super important donc voilà il
est pas là par les deux bouts film est
de bouffer
[Rires]
mathieu parent de me dire et je voudrais
qu'on remercie vaima la machine est il
de la télé au nadji madou inspire ce
moment moi de kabila il nous fait
l'honneur aussi de venir nous voir avec
sa maman c'est dazhou qui revient avec
dalida dazhou merci d'être avec nous et
merci d'avoir créé cette association
give back charity qui soutient des
projets humanitaires au congo notamment
elle aide les femmes qui ont été
victimes de violences sexuelles au congo
question quelle émission de m6 a fait la
plus mauvaise audience en 2019
une affiche une ambition intime avec
franck dubosc position a dit m c'est nos
missions team avec n'importe quoi parce
que de toute façon ça ne marche pas
c'est là des gens même logique
oui
audience
[Musique]
si les bras
j'ai trop quoi
un chat
m
après
à chaud
ça touche un français sur cinq
le handicap on est tous concernés donc
il faut qu'on soit tous mobilisés pour
changer la donne parce que chacun à
votre place vous pouvez changer la donne
invité une famille un goûter
d'anniversaire qu'un enfant handicapé
faire sa place en tant que collègue sur
une personne qui a un handicap tout
simplement accueillir la différence le
plus normalement possible c'est ça sur
lequel on travaille et chaque français
peut changer la donne ou qui commence à
voir la chine et ça m'a bien civile et
voudrait bien
[Musique]
là
mais
trois ans super maintenant
[Musique]
tu peux pas t'empêcher de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la trappe
pour regarder et achetez vous un peu
s'il vous plaît merci
est ce que vous voulez dire qu'est ce
qu'il a dit en loge tout à l'heure ouais
est-ce qu'on a 10 ans lofteurs parce que
je le dis aux téléspectateurs que maddie
en loge tout à l'heure alors mois ferme
ta gueule
[Rires]
c'est qu'on a tous les trois la même
passion qui nous a dit vous parler
d'attentât mais bien sûr c'est pas les
mariages comme toi ou dans un rêve je
racontais un truc qui vous m'avez dit
texto dans le rêve tu t'es cru chez tam
la fin de ta gueule du monde doit avoir
lieu on sait très bien où était-ce doit
tout le week end
merci qu'est ce qu'elle veut ce qui est
incroyable quand on regarde la pieuvre
et c'est qu'il ya treize prix nobel qui
ont étudié des choses dans la mer son
polar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu des révélations
matthieu delormeau je vous le dis
derrière l'a9 il y a et je n'ai pas
triché mathieu c'est que je n'ai rien
fait vous l'avez yes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]